The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So last lecture we started
with the strategy of using
perturbation theory to study
our statistical themes.
For example, we need to
evaluate a partition function
by integrating over all
configurations of a field.
Let's say n components
in d dimensions
with some kind of a weight that
we can write as e to the minus
beta H. And the
strategy of perturbation
was to find part
of this Hamiltonian
that we can calculate exactly.
And the rest of it, hopefully
treating as a small quantity
and doing perturbative
calculations.
Now, in the context of
the Landau-Ginzburg theory
that we wrote down,
this beta H0 was
bets described in
terms of Fourier modes.
So basically, we could
make a change of variables
to integrate over all
configurations of Fourier
modes.
And the same breakdown
of the weight
in the language
of Fourier modes.
Since the underlying
theories that we were writing
had translational symmetry,
every point in space
was the same as any other,
the composition in to modes
was immediately
accomplished by going
to Fourier representation.
And each component
of each q-value
would correspond to essentially
an independent weight
that we could expand
in some power series
in this parameter q, which is
an inverse in the wave length.
And the lowest
order terms are what
determines the longer
and longer wavelengths.
So there is some m of q
squared characterizing
this part of the Hamiltonian.
And since is real
space we had emphasized
some form of locality, the
interaction part in real space
could be written simply in terms
of a power series, let's say,
in m.
Which means that if we were
to then go to Fourier space,
things that are
local in real space
become non-local
in Fourier space.
And the first of those
terms that we treated
as a perturbation would
involve an integral
over four factors of m tilde.
Again, translational
invariance forces the four q's
that appear in the
multiplication to add up to 0.
So I would have m of q1
dot for dot with m of q2,
m of q3 dot for
dot with m of q4,
which is minus q1
minus q2 minus q3.
And I can go on and
do higher order.
So once we did this,
we could calculate
various-- let's say, two-point
correlation functions,
et cetera, in
perturbation theory.
And in particular, the
two-point correlation function
was related to the
susceptibility.
And setting q to 0,
we found an expression
for the inverse susceptibility
where the 0 order just
comes from the t that
we have over here.
And because of this perturbation
calculated to order of u,
we had 4u n plus 2 and
integral over modes
of just the variance
of the modes if y like.
Now, first thing
that we noted was
that the location of the point
at which the susceptibility
vanishes, or
susceptibility diverges
or its inverse vanishes is
no longer at t equals to 0.
But we can see just setting this
expression to 0 that we have
a tc, which is minus 4u n plus
2 integral d dk 2 pi to the d 1
over-- let's put the k
here, k squared, potentially
higher-order terms.
Now, this is an integral
that in dimensions above 2--
let's for time being focus
on dimensions above 2-- there
is no singularity
as k goes to 0.
k goes to 0, which is long
wavelength, is well-behaved.
The integral could
potentially be singular
if I were allowed to go
all the way to infinity,
but I don't go all the infinity.
All of my theories have an
underlying short wavelength.
And hence, there is a
maximum in the Fourier modes
which would render this
completely well-behaved
integral.
In fact, if I forget
higher-order term,
I could put them.
But if I forget
them, I can evaluate
what this correction tc is.
It is minus 4u n plus 2 over k.
This-- I've been writing--
symmetry at surface area
of a d dimensional unit sphere
divided by 2 pi to the d.
And then I have the integral
of k to the d minus 3,
which integrates to
lambda to the d minus 2
divided by d minus 2.
I wrote that
explicitly because we
are going to encounter this
combination a lot of times.
And so we will give
it a name k sub d.
So it's just the solid angle
in d dimensions divided by 2 pi
to the d.
OK, so essentially, in
dimensions greater than 2,
nothing much happens.
There is a shift in the location
of the singularity compared
to the Gaussian.
Because you are no
longer at the Gaussian,
you are at a theory that
has additional stabilizing
terms such as m to
the fourth, et cetera.
So there is no problem now for
p going to negative values.
The thing that was
more interesting
was that when we
looked at what happens
in the vicinity of this
new tc, and to lowest order
we got this form
of a divergence.
And then at the next
order, I had a correction.
Again, coming from this form,
4u n plus 2, an integral.
And actually, this was obtained
by taking the difference of two
of these factors
evaluated at p and tc.
That's what gave me
the t minus tc outside.
And then I had an integral that
involved two of these factors.
Presumably to be
consistent to lowest order,
I have to evaluate
them as small as I can.
And so I would have two factors
of k squared or k squared
plus something.
Presumably, higher-order terms.
The thing about these integrals
as opposed to the previous one
is that, again,
I can try to look
at the behavior at
large k and small k.
At large k, no
matter how many terms
I add to the series,
ultimately, I
will be concerned by
cutting it off by lambda.
Whereas, if I have
something that I
have set t equals to 0 in both
of these denominator factors,
I now have a
singularity at k goes
to 0 in dimensions less than 4.
The integral would blow up
in dimensions less than 4
if I am allowed to go all the
way to 0, which is arbitrarily
long wavelengths.
Now in principle, if
I am not exactly at tc
and I'm looking at singularity
as being away from tc,
I expect on physical
grounds that fluctuations
will persist up to some
correlation length.
So the shortest value of k
that I should really physically
be able to go to, irrespective
of how careful or careless
I am with the factors of t and
t minus tc that I put here,
is of the order of the
physical correlation length.
And as we saw, this
means that there
is a correction that
is of the form of u k
to the 4-- k squared psi
to the power of 4 minus d.
And I emphasized that the
dimensionless combination
of the parameter
u that potentially
can be added as a correction
to a number of order of 1
is u k squared divided by some--
multiplied by some length scale
to the power of 4 minus d.
Above four dimensions,
the integral
is convergent at small values.
And the integral
will be dominated
and the length scale
that would appear here
would be some kind of a
short distance cutoff,
like the averaging length.
Whereas in four dimensions with
divergence of the correlation
length is the thing that
will lead this perturbation
theory to be kind of
difficult and [INAUDIBLE].
So this is an example of a
divergent perturbation theory.
So what we are
going to do in order
to be able to make
sense out of it,
and see how this divergence
here can be translated
to a change in exponent, which
is what we are physically
expecting to occur, we
reorganize this perturbation
theory in a
conceptual way that is
helped by this perturbative
renormalization group approach.
So we keep the
perturbation theory,
but change the way that we
look at perturbation theory
by appealing to renormalization.
So you can see that throughout
doing this perturbation theory,
I end up having to do integrals
over modes that are defined
in the space of the
Fourier parameter q.
And a nice way to implement
this coarse graining that
has led to this field
theory is to imagine
that this integration is
over some sphere where
the maximum inverse
wavelength that is allowed,
or q number that is
allowed is some lambda.
And so the task that I
have on the first line
is to integrate over all
modes that live in this.
And just on physical
grounds, we don't
expect to get any singularities
from the modes that
are at the edge.
We expect to get singularities
by considering what's
going on at long
wavelengths or 0q.
So the idea of
renormalization group
was to follow three steps.
The first step was to do
coarse graining, which
was to take whatever your
shortest wavelength was,
make it b times
larger and average.
That's in real space.
In Fourier space,
what that amounts
to is to get rid of all of the
variations and frequencies that
are up to lambda over b.
So what I can do is to say that
I had a whole bunch of modes
m of q.
I am going to subdivide
them into two classes.
I will have the
modes sigma of q.
Maybe I will write it in
different color, sigma of q.
That are the ones
that sitting here.
So these are the sigmas.
And these correspond
to wave numbers
that are between lambda
over b and lambda.
And I will have a bunch
of other variables
that I will call m tilde.
And this wave close
to the singularity,
but now removed by an
amount lambda over b.
So essentially, getting
rid of the picture
where it had fluctuations
at short length scale
amounts to integrating
over Fourier modes that
represent your field that
lie in this integral.
So I want to do that as an
operation that is performed,
let's say, at the level
of the partition function.
So I can say that my original
integration can be broken up
into integration
over this m tilde
and the integration over sigma.
So that's just rewriting that
rightmost integral up there.
And then I have a
weight exponential.
OK, let's write
it out explicitly.
So the weight is composed
of beta H0 and the u.
Now, we note that the beta H0
part, just as we did already
for the case of the
Gaussian, does not
mix up these two
classes of modes.
So I can write that part
as an integral from 0
to lambda over b dd 2 pi over d.
And these are things
that are really inside,
so I could also label
them by q lesser.
So I have m tilde
of q lesser squared.
And this multiplies
t plus k q lesser
squared and so forth over 2.
I have a similar term,
which is the modes that
are between lambda
over b and lambda.
So I just simply changed or
broke my overall integration
in beta H0 into two parts.
Now I have the higher q numbers.
And these are sigma
of q larger squared.
Again, same weight,
t plus k q larger
squared and so forth over 2.
Make sure this minus
is in line with this.
And then I have,
of course, the u.
So then I have a minus u.
Now, I won't write
this explicitly.
I will write it explicitly
on the next board.
But clearly, implicitly it
involves both m tilde and sigma
mixed up into each other.
So I have just rewritten
my partition function
after subdividing it into
these two classes of modes
and just hiding all
of the complexity
in this function
that mixes the two.
So let's rewrite this.
I have integral over the modes
that I would like to keep.
The m tilde I
would like to keep.
And there is a weight
associated with them
that will, therefore,
not be integrated.
This is the integral from 0
to lambda over b dd k lesser 2
pi to the d t plus k, k lesser
q lesser squared, et cetera.
And then I have tilde
of q lesser squared.
Now, if I didn't have
this there, the u,
I could immediately perform the
Gaussian integrals over sigmas.
Indeed, we already did this.
And the answer would
be e to the minus--
there are n-components
to this vector.
So the answer is going
to be multiplied by n.
1/2 is because the square root
that I get from each mode.
I get a factor of
volume integral dd
q larger 2 pi to the d
integrated from lambda over v
to lambda log of t plus k q
greater squared and so forth.
So if I didn't have
the u, this would
be the answer for doing
the Gaussian integration.
But I have the u,
so what should I do?
The answer is very simple.
I write it as e to the minus
u m tilde m sigma average.
So what I have done is to say
that with this weight, that
is a Gaussian
weight for sigma, I
average the function
e to the minus u.
If you like, this
is a Gaussian sigma.
So to sort of write it
explicitly, what I have stated
is an average where
I integrate out
the high-frequency
short wavelength modes
is by definition integrate over
all configurations of sigma
with the Gaussian weight
whatever object you have,
and then normalize
by the Gaussian.
Of course, in our case, our
O depends both on sigma and m
tilde, so the result
of these averaging
will be a function of in tilde.
And indeed, I can write this as
an integral over m tilde of q
with a new weight, e to the
minus beta H tilde, which
only depends on m tilde
because I got rid of
and I integrated
over the sigmas.
And by definition,
my beta H tilde
that depends only on
m tilde has a part
that is the integral from 0
to lambda over b dd q lesser
2 pi to the d the Gaussian
weight over the range of modes
that are allowed.
There is a part that is
just this constant term when
I take care-- if I write
it in this fashion,
there is an overall constant.
Clearly, what this constant is,
is the free energy of the modes
that I have integrated,
assuming that they are Gaussian,
in this interval.
The answer is
proportional to volume.
But as usual, when
we are thinking
about weights and probabilities,
overall constants don't matter.
But I can certainly continue
to write that over here.
So that part went to here,
this part went to here.
And so the only
part that is left
is minus log of d to the
minus u of m tilde and sigma
after I get rid of the sigmas.
So far, I have done things
that are extremely general.
But now I note that I
am interested in doing
perturbation.
So the only place that I
haven't really evaluated things
is where this u is appearing
inside the exponential log
average, et cetera.
So what I can do is
I can perturbatively
expand this
exponential over here.
So I will get log of 1 minus u,
which is approximately minus u.
So the first term here would
be u averaged Gaussian.
The next term will be
minus 1/2 u squared
average minus u average
squared and so forth.
So you can see that the
variance appeared in this stage.
And generally, the l-th term
in the series would be minus 1
to the l divided by l factorial.
And we saw this already.
The log of e to the something
is the generator of cumulants.
So this would be
the l-th power of u,
the cumulant here would appear.
And again, the cumulant
would serve the function
of cutting off connected
pieces as we shall see shortly.
So that's what we
are going to do.
We are going to insert
the u's, all things that
go beyond the Gaussian--
but initially,
just the m to the fourth
part-- inside this series
and term by term calculate
the corrections to this weight
that we get after we
integrate out the long lambda.
Or sorry, the short wavelength
modes or the long q modes.
OK?
So let's focus on
this first term.
So what is this u that depends
on both m tilde and sigma?
And I have the expression
for u up there.
So I can write it as u integral
dd q1 dd q2 dd q3 to be
symmetric in all
of the four q's.
I write an integration
over the fourth q,
but then enforce it
by a delta function
that the sum of the
q's should be 0.
And then I have
four factors of m,
but an m depending on
which part of the q space
I am encountering is either
a sigma or an m tilde.
So without doing
anything wrong, I
can replace each m with
an m tilde plus sigma.
So depending on where my q1
is in the integrations from 0
to lambda, I will be
encountering either this
or this.
And then I have the dot
product of that with m tilde q2
plus sigma of q2.
And then I have the
dot product that
would correspond to m tilde
of q3 plus sigma of q3
with m tilde of q4
plus sigma of q4.
So that's the structure
of my [INAUDIBLE].
And again, what I have
to do in principle
is to integrate out the sigmas
keeping the m tildes when
I perform this
averaging over here.
So let's write down,
if I were to expand
this thing before
the integration, what
are the types of terms
that I would get?
And I'll give them names.
One type of term
that is very easy
is when I have m tilde of q1
dotted with m tilde of Q2,
m tilde of q3 dotted
with m tilde of q4.
If I expand this so
there's 2 terms per bracket
and there are 4 brackets, so
there are 16 terms, only 1
of these terms is of this
variety out of the 16.
What I will do is
also now introduce
a diagrammatic representation.
Whenever I see an m tilde, I
will include a straight line.
Whenever I see a sigma, I
will include a wavy line.
So this entity that
I have over here
is composed of four of
these straight lines.
And I will indicate that by
this diagram, q1, q2, q3, q4.
And the reason is, of
course-- first of all,
there are four of these.
So this is a so-called vertex
in a diagrammatic representation
that has four lines.
And secondly, the lines are not
all totally equivalent because
of the way that the dot
products are arranged.
Say, q1 and q2 that are dot
product together are distinct,
let's say, from q1 and q3 that
are not dot product together.
And to indicate that,
I make sure that there
is this dotted line in
the vertex that separates
and indicates which two are
dot product to each other.
Now, the second class
of diagram comes
when I replace one of the
m tildes with a sigma.
So I have sigma of q1
dotted with m tilde
of q2, m tilde of q3
dotted with m tilde of q4.
Now clearly, in this
case, I had a choice
of four factors of m tilde
to replace with this.
So of the 16 terms in
this expansion, 4 of them
belong to this class.
Which if I were to
represent diagrammatically,
I would have one of
the legs replaced
with a wavy line and
all the other legs
staying as solid lines.
The third class of
terms correspond
to replacing two of the
m tildes with sigmas.
Now here again, I have a
choice whether the second one
is a partner of
the first one that
became sigma, such as
this one, sigma of q1
dotted with sigma of
q2, m tilde of q3 dotted
with m tilde of q4.
And then clearly,
I could have chosen
one pair or the other pair
to change into sigmas.
So there are two terms
that are like this.
And diagrammatically,
the wavy lines
belong to the same
branch of this object.
OK, next.
Keep going.
Actually, I have
another thing when
I replace two of the
m tildes with sigma,
but now belonging to two
different elements of this dot
product.
So I could have sigma of q1
dotted with m tilde of q2.
And then I have sigma of q3
dotted with m tilde of q4.
In which case, in each of the
pairs I had a choice of two
for replacing m
tilde with sigma.
So that's 2 times 2.
There are four terms
that have this character.
And if I were to represent
them diagrammatically,
I would need to
put two wavy lines
on two different branches.
And then I have the possibility
of three things replaced.
So I have sigma of q1 sigma of
q2 sigma of q3 m tilde of q4.
And again, now it's
the other way around.
One term is left out
of 4 to be m tilde.
So this is, again,
a degeneracy of 4.
And diagrammatically, I have
three lines that are wavy
and one line that is solid.
And at the end of
story, 6, I will
have one diagram which
is all sigmas, which
can be represented
essentially by all wavy lines.
And to check that I didn't make
any mistake in my calculation,
the sum of these
numbers better be 16.
So that's 5, 7, 11, 15, 16.
All right?
Now, the next step of the
story is to do these averages.
So I have to do the average.
Now, the first term
doesn't involve any sigmas.
All of my averages
here are obtained
by integrating over sigmas.
If there is no
sigmas to integrate,
after I do the averaging
here I essentially
get the same thing back.
So I will get this
same expression.
And clearly, that
would be a term
that would contribute to
my beta H tilde, which
is identical to what
I had originally.
It is, again, m to the fourth.
So that we understand.
Now, the second
term here, what is
the average that
I have to do here?
I have one factor of sigma
with which I can average.
But the weight that I
have is even in sigma.
So the average of sigma, which
is Gaussian-distributed, is 0.
So this will give me 0.
And clearly, here
also there is a term
that involves three
factors of sigma.
Again, by symmetry this
will average out to 0.
Now, there is a way of
indicating what happens here.
See, what happens
here is that I will
have to do an average
of this thing.
The m tildes are not
part of the averaging.
They just go out.
The average moves all
the way over here.
And the average of sigma of q1,
sigma of q2, I know what it is.
It is going to be-- I could
have just written it over here.
It's 2 pi to the d delta
function q1 plus q2
divided by k q squared.
Maybe I'll explicitly
write it over here.
So what we have here is
that the average of sigma
of q1 with some index sigma
of q2 with some other index
is-- first of all, the two
indices have to be the same.
I have a delta
function q1 plus q2.
And then I have t plus k
q1 squared and so forth.
So it's my usual Gaussian.
So essentially, you can see
that one immediate consequence
of this averaging is that
previously these things had
two different momenta
and potentially
two different indices.
They get to be the same thing.
And the fact that
the labels that
were assigned to this,
the q and the index alpha,
are forced to be the same,
we can diagrammatically
indicate by making
this a closed line.
So we are going to represent
the result of that averaging
with essentially taking--
these two lines are unchanged.
They can be whatever they were.
These two lines really
are joined together
through this process.
So we indicate them that way.
And similarly, when I do
the same thing over here,
I do the averaging of
this and the answer
I can indicate by leaving
these two lines by themselves
and joining these two wavy
lines together in this fashion.
Now, when you do--
this one we said is 0.
So there's essentially one that
is left, which is number 6.
For number 6, we
do our averaging.
And for that we have to use-
for average or a product of four
sigmas that are
Gaussian-distributed Wick's
theorem.
So one possibility is that
sigma 1 and sigma 2 are joined,
and then sigma 4 and
sigma 3 have to be joined.
So basically, I took
sigma 1 and sigma 2
and joined them, sigma 3 and
sigma 4 that I joined them.
But another possibility
is I can take
sigma 1 with sigma 3 or sigma 4.
So there are really two choices.
And then I will have a
diagram that is like this.
Now, each one of these
operations and diagrams
really stands for some
integration and result.
And let's for example,
pick our number 3.
For number 3, what
we are supposed to do
is to do the integration.
Sorry.
First of all, number 3 has
a numerical factor of 2.
This is something that
is proportional to u
when we take the average.
I have in principle to do
integration over q1 q2 q3 q4.
OK.
The m tilde of q3 and m
tilde of q4 in this diagram
were not averaged over.
So that term remains.
I did the averaging
over q1 and q2.
When I did that averaging,
I, first of all,
got a delta alpha alpha because
those were two things that
were dot product to
each other, so they
were carrying the same
index to start with.
I have a 2 pi to the d, a
delta function q1 plus q2.
And I have t plus k q1 squared.
Now, delta alpha alpha.
Summing over alpha
gives a factor of n.
And when you look
at these diagrams,
quite generally
whenever you see a loop,
with a loop you would associate
the factor of n because
of the index that runs
and gets summed over.
So this answer is going to
be proportional to 2 u n.
Now, q1 and q2 are
said to be 0, the sum.
So this is 0.
So q3 and q4 have
to add up to 0.
So the part that involves
q3 and q4, the m tilde,
essentially I will
get an integral dd--
let's say whatever q3.
It doesn't matter because
it's an index of integration.
I have m tilde of q3 squared.
And again, q3, it
is something that
goes with one of these m tildes.
So this is an integration that I
have to do between 0 and lambda
over b.
So there is essentially
one integration
left because q1 and q2
are left to be the same.
So this is an integral.
Let's call the
integration variable
that was q1-- I could k,
it doesn't matter-- 2 pi
to the d the same integral
that we've seen before.
Except that since this
originated from the sigmas,
the integration here is
from lambda over b lambda.
So this is basically a number
that I can take, say, out here
and regard as a
coefficient that multiplies
a term that is m tilde squared.
And similarly, 4.
4.
We said we have four
diagrams of his variety,
so this would be a
contribution that is 4u.
I can read out the whole--
write out the whole thing.
Certainly, I have all of this.
I have all of this.
In that case, I have m tilde
q3 m tilde-- well, let's see.
I have m tilde of
q2 m tilde of q4.
And they carry different
indices because they
came from two
different dot products.
And then I have to do
an average over sigma 1
and sigma 3 which carry
different indices that
are for beta.
2 pi to the d delta function
q1 plus q3 e plus k q1 squared.
Again, since q1 plus q3 is 0 and
the sum of the four q's is 0,
these two have to add up to 0.
So the answer, again, will
be written as 4u integral 0
to lambda over b dd of
some q divided by 2 pi
to the b m tilde of q squared.
And then actually,
the same integration,
lambda over d lambda dd
k 2 pi to the d 1 over 2
plus k squared.
So out of the six
terms, two are 0.
Two are explicitly
calculated over here.
One is trivially
just m to the fourth.
The last one is basically
summing up all of these things.
But these explicitly do
not depend on m tilde.
So I'll just call the result of
doing all of this sum V delta f
v at level 1.
In the same way that integrating
the modes sigma that I'm not
interested and
averaging over them
gave a constant of integration,
that constant of integration
gets corrected to
order of u over here.
I don't need to explicitly
take care of it.
So given all of
this information,
let's write down what our last
line from the previous board
is.
So our intent was to
calculate a weight that
governed these
coarse-grained modes.
And our answer is
that, first of all,
we will get a bunch of constants
delta f v 0 plus delta f v 1
that we don't really care.
They're just an
overall change that
doesn't matter for
the probabilities.
It's just contribution
to the free energy.
And then we start to get things.
And to the lowest
order what we had
was replacing the
Gaussian weight,
but only over this permitted
set of wavelengths.
So I have dd q
lesser, let's say,
2 pi to the d t plus k q
lesser squared and so forth.
Divided by 2 m
tilde of q squared.
Then, term number 1 in
the series gave me what?
It gave me something that
was equivalent to my u
if I were to Fourier
transform back to real space,
m to the fourth.
Except that my cutoff has
been shifted by lambda over b.
So I don't want to
bother to write down
that full form in
terms of Fourier modes.
Essentially, if I want
to write this explicitly,
it is just like that
line that I have,
except that for the
integrations I'll
have to explicitly indicate
0 to lambda over b.
So the only terms that
we haven't included
are the ones that are over here.
Now, you look at
those terms and you
find that the structure
of these terms
is precisely what
we have over here.
Except that there
is a modification.
There is a constant term
that is added from this one
and there's a constant term
that is added from that one.
So the effect of those
things I can capture
by changing the parameters
t to something else t tilde.
So you can see that to order
of u squared that I haven't
calculated, to order
of u, the only effect
of this coarse graining is to
modify this one parameter so
that t goes to t tilde.
It certainly depends on how
much I coarse grain things.
And this is the original t
plus the sum of these things.
So I will have 2-- n
plus 2 u integral dd k 2
pi to the d 1 over
t plus k k squared.
And presumably,
higher-order terms
are allowed, going from
0 to lambda over here.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When you have an integration
over x, if you have previously
defined lambda to be
a cutoff in k space,
might it be-- is it
1 over b lambda then?
Or, is it b over lambda?
Because--
PROFESSOR: OK.
You're right.
So previously, maybe the
best way to write this
would have been that there
is a shortest length scale a.
So I should really
indicate what's
happening here as shortest
length scale having gone
to v. And there is
always a relationship
between the a and lambda,
which is inverse relation,
but there are factors of 2
pi and things like that which
I don't really want to bother.
It doesn't matter.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
it be t tilde is
equal to 2 plus 4 multiplied by?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Good.
Because the coefficients
here are divided by 2.
So that 2 I forgot.
And I should restore it.
And if I had gone a
little bit further,
I would have then started
comparing this formula
with this formula.
And I realized that I
should have had the 4.
Clearly, the two formula are
telling me the same thing.
You can see that they
are almost exactly
the same with the exception
of how much integration.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One other thing.
Are bounds of those
integrals for your tb,
shouldn't they be
lambda over d to lambda?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Lambda over d to lambda.
And it is because of
that that I don't really
have to worry because we
saw that when we were doing
straightforward
perturbation theory,
the reason that perturbation
theory was blowing up
in my face was integrating
all the way to the origin.
And the trick of renormalization
group is by averaging of there,
I don't really yet
reach the singularity
that I would have
at k equals to 0.
This integral by itself is not
problematic at k equals to 0,
but future integrals would.
Any other mistakes?
No.
All right.
But the other part
of this story is
that the effect of this coarse
graining at lowest order mu
was to modify this parameter t.
But importantly,
to do nothing else.
That is, we can see that
in this Hamiltonian that we
had written, the
k that is rescaled
is the same as the old k.
And the u is the
same as the old u.
That is, to the lowest order the
only effect of coarse graining
was to modify the parameter
that covers coefficient
of t squared.
But we have not
completed our task
of constructing a
renormalization group.
Renormalization group
had three steps.
The most difficult step,
which was the coarse graining
we have completed, but now we
have generated a grainy picture
in which the shortest
wavelengths are a factor of b
larger than what we had before.
In order to make our
pictures look the same,
we had to do steps
2 and 3 of rg.
Step 2 was to shrink
all of the lengths
in real space, which amounts
to q prime being b times q.
And that will restore the
upper part of the q integration
to be lambda.
And there was a
rescaling that we
had to perform for the magnitude
of the fluctuations which
amounted to replacing the m
tilde of q with z N prime.
So this would be, if
you like, q lesser
and this would be m prime.
Now, the reason these
steps are trivial
is because just
whenever I see a q,
I replace it with
b inverse q prime.
Whenever I see an m tilde,
I replace it with z m prime.
So then I will find the
Hamiltonian that characterizes
the m prime variables, the
rg implemented variables,
which is-- OK, there is a
bunch of constants out front.
There is the fv.
Actually, it's 0 delta fv1.
In the sign, I had
to put as plus.
But really, it doesn't matter.
Then, I go and write
down what I have.
The integration over q
prime after the rescaling is
performed goes back to the same
cutoff or the same shortest
wavelength as before.
Except that when I do
this replacement of q
lesser with q prime, I will get
a factor of b to the minus d
down here.
And there are b integrations.
And then I have t tilde.
The next term is k tilde, but
k tilde is the same thing as k.
Goes with q squared.
So this becomes q prime
squared, and then I
will get a b to the minus 2.
Higher orders will get more
factors of b to the minus 2
over 2.
And then I have m tilde,
which is replaced by z.
And there are two of them.
I will get m prime
of q prime squared.
If I were to
explicitly now write
the factors that go
in construction of u,
since u had three
integrations over q--
left board over there-- I
will get three integrations
over q prime giving me a
factor of b to the minus 3d.
And then I have four factors
of m tilde that become m prime.
Along the way, I will
pick up four factors of z.
And then, of course,
order of u squared.
So under this three
steps of rg, what
happened was that I generated
t prime, which was z
squared b to the
minus d t tilde.
I generated u prime,
which was z to the fourth
b to the minus 3d
u, the original u.
And I generated
the k prime, which
was z squared b to
the minus d minus 2 k.
And I could do the same for
various other parameters.
Now again, we come
up with this issue
of what to choose for zeta.
Sorry, for z.
And what I had
said previously was
that we went through all
of these exercise of doing
the Gaussian model
via rg in order
to have an anchoring point.
And there we saw that the
thing that we were interested
was to look at the point where
k prime was the same as k.
So let's stick with
that choice and see
what the consequences are.
So choose z such that
k prime is the same
a k, which means the I
choose my z to be b to the 1
plus d over 2 exactly
as I had done previously
for the Gaussian model.
So now I can substitute
these values.
And therefore,
see that following
a rescaling by a factor of
b, the value of my t prime.
z squared b to the minus d.
I will get b to the power
of 2 plus d minus d.
So that would give me b squared.
And I have t plus 4u n plus 2.
This integral from
lambda over b to lambda
to dk 2 pi to the
d 1 over d plus k,
k squared, and so forth.
Presumably, order of u squared.
And that my factor
of u rescaled by b.
I have to put four factors of z.
So I will get b
to the 4 plus 2d,
and then 3d gets subtracted,
so I will get b to the 4 minus
d and u again.
But presumably,
order of u squared.
So the first factors
are precisely the things
that we had done and obtained
for the Gaussian model.
So the only thing that we
gained by this exercise so far
is this correction to t.
We will see that that correction
is not that important.
And in order to really
gain an understanding,
we have to go to the next order.
But let's use this
opportunity to also make
some changes of
terminology that is useful.
So clearly, the way that
we had constructed this--
and in particular,
if you are thinking
about averaging over spins,
et cetera, in real space--
the natural thing
to think about is
that maybe your b is a factor
of 2, or a factor of 3.
You sort of group things by
a factor of twice as much
and then do the averaging.
But when you look at
things from the perspective
of this momentum shell,
this b can be anything.
And it turns out to be useful
just as a language tool, not as
a conceptual tool, to make
this b to be very close to 1
so that effectively you are
just removing a very, very
tiny, thin shell
around the boundary.
So essentially what I am saying
is choose b that is almost 1,
but maybe a little
bit shifted from 1.
Then clearly, as b
goes to 1, then t prime
has to go to t--
prime has to go to u.
So what I can do is I
can define t prime scaled
by a factor of 1 plus delta l
to be t plus a small amount dt
by dl.
And in order of delta l squared.
And similarly, I can write u
prime to be u plus delta l du
by dl and higher order.
And the reason is that if we now
look at the parameter space--
t, u, whatever-- the
effect of this procedure
rather than being some jump
from some point to another point
because we rescaled
by a factor of b
is to go to a nearby point.
So these things,
dt by dl, du by dl,
essentially point
to the direction
in which the parameters
would change.
And so they allow you
to replace these jumps
that you have by things that are
called flows in this parameter
space.
So basically, you have
constructed flows and vectors
that describe the flows
in this parameter space.
Now, if I do that
over here, we can also
see some other things emerging.
So b squared I can write
as 1 plus 2 delta l.
And then here, I have t.
Now clearly here, if d was
1, the integral would be 0.
I am integrating
over a tiny shell.
So the answer here
when b goes to 1
is really just the area
of that sphere multiplied
by the thickness.
And so what do I get?
I get 4u n plus 2 is just
the overall coefficient.
Then, what is the surface area?
I have the solid angle
divided by 2 pi to the d.
OK, you divide solid
angle divided by 2 pi
to the d to be kd.
What's the value of
the integrand on shell?
On shell, I have to
replace k with the lambda.
So I will get t plus
k lambda squared.
Actually, the surface area is
Sd lambda to the d minus 1.
But then the thickness
is lambda delta l.
The second one is
actually very easy.
It is 1 plus 4 minus
b delta l times u.
So you can see that if I match
things to order of delta l,
I get the following rg flows.
So the left-hand side is
t plus delta l dt by dl.
The right-hand side-- if I
expand, there is a factor of t.
So that it gets rid of.
And I'm left with a term that is
proportional to delta l, whose
coefficient on the
left-hand side is dt by dl.
And the right-hand side, I
get either a factor of 2t
from multiplying the 2 delta
l with t or from multiplying
the 1 with the result
of this integration.
I will get a 4u n
plus 2 kd lambda
to the d divided by t
plus k lambda squared.
And I don't need to
evaluate any integrals.
And the second flow equation
for the parameter u du by dl
is 4 minus d u.
Now, clearly in the
language of flows,
a fixed point is when
there is no flow.
So I could have dt by dl
du by dl need to be 0.
And du by dl being 0
immediately tells ms
that u star has to be 0.
And if I set u
star equals to 0, I
will see that t
star has to be 0.
So these equations
have one and only
one fixed point at this order.
And then looking for relevance
and irrelevance of going away
from the fixed point can
be captured by linearizing.
That is, I write my t to
be t star plus delta l.
Of course, my t star
and u star are both 0.
But in general, if
they were not at 0,
I would linearize my in general,
non-linear rg recursions
by going slightly away
from the fixed point.
And then the linearized
form of the equation
would say that going away be a
small amount delta t delta u--
and there could be more and
more of these operators-- an
be written in terms of a matrix
multiply delta t and delta u.
And clearly, the matrix
for u is very simple.
It is simply proportional
to 4 minus d delta u.
The matrix for t?
Well, there's two terms.
First of all, there is this 2.
And then if I am
taking a derivative,
there will be a derivative
of this expression
because there is a
t-dependence here.
But ultimately, since
I'm evaluating it
at u star equals to 0, I don't
need to include that term here.
But if I now make
a variation in u,
I will get an
off-diagonal term here,
which is k lambda squared.
So these two can
combine with each other.
Now, looking for
relevance or irrelevance
is then equivalent-- previously,
we were talking about it
in terms of the full equations
with b that could have been
anything, but now we
have gone to this limit
of infinitesimal b.
Then, what I have to do
is to find the eigenvalues
of the matrix that I
have for these flows.
Now, a matrix that has this
structure where there's
0 on one side of the
diagonal, I immediately
know that the eigenvalues
are 2 and 4 minus d.
So basically, depending
on whether I'm
in dimensions greater
than 4 or less than 4,
I will have either two or
one relevant direction.
In particular, if I look
at what is happening
for d that is greater than
4-- for d greater than 4,
I will just have one
relevant direction.
And if I look at the
behavior and the flows
that I am allowed to have in
the two parameters t and u.
Now, if my Hamiltonian
only has t and u,
I'm only allowed
to look at the case
where u is positive
in order not to have
weights that are unbounded.
My fixed point occurs at 0, 0.
And then one simple thing is
that if u is 0, it will stay 0.
And then dt by dl is 2t.
So I know that I always
have an eigen-direction that
is along the t and is flowing
away with a velocity of 2
if you like.
The other eigen-direction is
not the axis t equals to 0.
Because if t is 0
originally but 0 is nonzero,
this term will generate some
positive amount of t for me.
So if I start
somewhere on this axis,
t will go in the direction
of becoming positive.
Above four dimensions,
you will become less.
So above four
dimension, you can see
that the general
trend of flows is
going to be something like this.
Indeed, there has to be
a second eigen-direction
because I'm dealing
with a 2 by 2 matrix.
And if you look at
it carefully, you'll
find that the second
eigen-direction is down here
and corresponds to a
negative eigenvalue.
So I basically would be having
flows that go towards that.
And in general, the
character of the flows,
if I have parameters
somewhere here,
they would be flowing there.
If I have parameters
somewhere here,
they would be flowing there.
So physically, I have something
like iron in five dimension,
for example.
And it corresponds to
being somewhere here.
When I change the temperature
of iron in five dimension
and I execute some
trajectory such as this,
all of the points that are on
this side of the trajectory
on their flow will
go to a place where
u becomes small and
t becomes positive.
So I will essentially go to
this Gaussian-like fixed point
that describes
independent spins.
All the things
that are down here,
which previously in
the Gaussian model
we could not describe,
because the Gaussian model
did not allow me to
go to t negative.
Because now I have
a positive view,
I have no problem with that.
And I find that essentially
I go to large negative t
corresponding to
some positive u.
I can figure out what the
amount of magnetization is.
And so then in
between them, there
is a trajectory that separates
paramagnetic and ferromagnetic
behavior.
And clearly, that
trajectory at long scales
corresponds to the
fixed point that
is simply the gradient squared.
Because all the other
terms went to 0, so
we know all of the
correlation functions,
et cetera, that we should
see in this system.
Unfortunately, if I look for
d less than 4, what happens
is that I still have
the same fixed point.
And actually , the
eigen-directions don't change
all that much.
u equals to 0 is still
an eigen-direction
that has relevance, too.
But the other direction
changes from being
irrelevant to being relevant.
So I have something like this.
And the natural
types of flows that I
get kind of look like this.
And now if I take my
iron in three dimensions
and change its temperature,
I go from behavior
that is kind of
paramagnetic-like
to ferromagnetic-like.
And there is a transition point.
But that transition
point I don't
know what fixed
point it goes to.
I have no idea.
So the only difference
by doing this analysis
from what we had done just
on the basis of scaling
and Gaussian theory,
et cetera, is
that we have located
the shift in t
with u, which is what
we had done before.
So was it worth it?
The answer is up to here, no.
But let's see if you had
gone one step further what
would have happened.
The series is an
alternating series.
So the next order term
that I get here I expect
will come with some
negative u squared.
So let's say there will
be some amount of work
that I have to do.
And I calculate something
that is minus a u squared.
I do some amount of
work and I calculate
something that is
minus b u squared.
But then you can see that if
I search for the fixed point,
I will find another
one at u star, which
is 4 minus d over b.
So I will find another point.
And indeed, we'll find
that things that left here
will go to that point.
And so that point has
one direction here.
It was relevant that
becomes irrelevant.
And the other
direction is the analog
of this direction, which
still remains relevant,
but with modified exponents.
We will figure out what that is.
So the next step
is to find this b,
and then everything
would be resolved.
The only thing to then realize
is, what are we perturbing it?
Because the whole
idea of perturbation
theory is that you should
have a small parameter.
And if we are
perturbing a u and then
basing our results on
what is happening here,
the location of this
fixed point better
be small-- close
to the original one
around which I am perturbing.
So what do I have to make small?
4 minus d.
So we thought we were
making a perturbation in u,
but in order to have a small
quantity the only thing that we
can do is to stay very
close to four dimension
and make a perturbation
expansion around four
dimension.